[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABI FERRARA: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 197 of the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform" podcast.
I am Gabi.
And I'm here with my
colleague Aja Hammerly.
Hi, Aja.
AJA HAMMERLY: Hey, Gabi.
GABI FERRARA: Today we talk with
Matthew Tamsett and Ravi Upreti
from Qubit about
AI recommendations.
And later we have a
question of the week
about Windows containers.
AJA HAMMERLY: But
first, it's time
for Cool Thing of the Week.
I've got one, Gabi.
And we'll put a link
in the show notes.
But there's a blog post entitled
"A Developer Goes to a DevOps
Conference."
And it does one of the
most accurate and concise
descriptions of what DevOps
actually is and kind describes
DevOps culture for
those who haven't
been involved in the community.
And I really recommend
you give it a read.
It's a really short read, maybe
one, two, three minutes most.
GABI FERRARA: We also
have another blog post,
but this one's on the
"Google Cloud" blog post.
It's called "Build is
Bringing Advanced Continuous
Integration, Continuous
Deployment for GitHub."
Basically every time you
can trigger deployment,
every time you have a PR merged.
And deployments are integration.
AJA HAMMERLY: Speaking
of Cloud Build,
the other thing I
wanted to point out
is My Cool Thing of the Week was
that Cloud Build was called out
by Forester as a best
in class CI/CD solution.
We'll put a link to the
"Google Cloud Platform" blog
post about that.
But I wanted to say that
Cloud Build's really cool.
And it's great to see the
community finally recognizing
that.
GABI FERRARA:
That's so deserved.
And then we have six strategies
for scaling your serverless
applications.
So it basically
talks about six ways
that you can scaling
capabilities over serverless
by using different maximum of
instances, using [INAUDIBLE],,
and other tips that you
can read on the blog post.
So go there and check it out.
So it's a quick read.
And now let's go
to our interview
with the folks on Qubit.
AJA HAMMERLY: So our guests
today are from Qubit.
How about y'all
introduce yourselves?
RAVI UPRETI: All
right, I'm Ravi.
I work as lead platform
continue with Qubit,
which means I wear
different hats, being
an individual contributor
to actually making
sure the platform engineers
are happy and engaged.
Responsibility would be
to make sure our core data
pipeline is running fine.
We are not lagging behind.
We are real time and making
sure all the systems are
up and running.
MATTHEW TAMSETT:
Hey, I'm Matthew,
I'm the lead data
scientist here at Qubit.
I've been here for
about three years.
Before that I was an
experimental particle
physicist.
And I worked at CERN.
And since leaving academia,
I've been working Qubit Festival
here as a data scientist
and more recently,
as a lead, which means I lead a
small team of about three data
scientists who use statistics,
machine learning, and tools
like this to try and create
a better online experience
for our customers' customers.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
GABI FERRARA: So you said,
Matt, that you were a physicist.
And now you work
as data science.
How it was like to work
as a physicist turning
to data scientist now?
MATTHEW TAMSETT: It really
is surprisingly common.
So when I first graduated
after finishing my PhD,
there was this
strange uncertainty
that opened up in front
of me and in front
of lots of my colleagues,
where we didn't really
know what to do.
You could carry on in physics,
or you could get another job.
But no one was really
clear what that meant.
But over the next
four years, I started
to hear this term data science
coming up more and more.
And at first, I didn't
really know what it meant.
And then after sort of
investigating it a bit more,
we saw--
me and my colleagues realized
that there was this whole world
out there emerging to do with
the proliferation of data
and high-performance computing
and things like this.
That meant there was
a whole new area where
we could apply very
similar skills to those
we'd used in our academic
lives but in industry.
So at fist, the whole
idea of leaving academia
was a bit scary.
So I think when I
learned more about it,
I started to realize
it actually it
was quite similar to that
everyday life in academia.
You still had the
same sort of problems
where you had like
huge data sets,
and you had-- it wasn't really
clear what the noisy signals
in them meant.
And there was now
this place where
I could work and apply those
same skills but in industry.
GABI FERRARA: So what does Qubit
does with that data science
and as a company?
MATTHEW TAMSETT: We
do a lot of things.
I think what you could say
is we sort of split what
we're doing to sort of
a few different realms.
The first one is just
simply measurement.
So Qubit's history is
rooted in A/B testing,
where you had multiple
variants of a single website.
And what you wanted to
know is which one of those
works best for my user
base at large or maybe
for individual groups
of users within that.
And measuring the difference
between those two things
is not necessarily
an easy problem.
The reason it's not
necessarily easy
is because you don't
really care about things
like click-through rates
or conversion rates.
You really want to care about
things like revenue and loyalty
and things like this.
And these can be quite
complicated noisy
distributions.
So one of the
things my team does
is work on modeling these
revenue distributions
and looking for
small differences
that you can measure by changing
the website in various ways.
On top of that, we also try
and predict things about users.
So Qubit has access to
what we collect, like
a vast store of
behavioral information
to do with how individual
businesses interact
with the website.
And one great thing
you can do with that
is use an individual's
historic data
to change the online experience
and to personalize this,
we'd say.
So if you look at a
lot of hats, then we
want to show you the
most relevant hats.
ML and data sites
gives you a way
of doing that not only in
the rearwards-looking way,
but also in a more
forward-looking predictive way.
So my team spends a reasonable
time building models
to try and predict interesting
facets of these uses
that we can then use to
personalize the experience,
whether this is from
recommendation models, which
products we think you're
going to need to engage with,
whether you're going to churn,
what your next spend will be,
things like that.
Then in addition, we
also do a lot of work
around dividing our customers'
customers again up into sets
or clusters of people that
behave in similar ways
partially to allow our
clients to understand
who is interacting with
their website and why.
But also so that we can build
these more specific models off
of them that take
into account, you
know, different
facets of the users.
GABI FERRARA: I
know your product
works because I'm a customer
for one of your customers.
MATTHEW TAMSETT: Oh, yeah?
GABI FERRARA: And I do receive
recommendations all the time.
And I ended up
buying everything.
Between giving this
value to your customers,
do you think the
impact is also bigger,
I mean on revenue, of course?
But like, there's this merchant
that because I bought a baby
bag, they think I
have a baby now.
And they keep sending
me baby stuff.
But I want to say to
them, I don't have a baby.
[BABY CRYING]
MATTHEW TAMSETT: Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: So do you
think the aggregates help
people shop?
MATTHEW TAMSETT: I think at
its most basic level, it does.
So like the simplest
recommendation algorithms
you can come up
with just use facets
of the population at
whole to try and work out
what you're going to do next.
In that case, the
most common action
of people who
bought baby bags is
to buy other
baby-related things.
I think the challenge is
taking that sort of global view
and making it more nuanced
to you as a consumer,
either by building algorithms
that are clever enough
to realize that, OK, we've shown
you these baby outfits five
or six times, and you're
not engaging with them.
Maybe we should show
you something different.
Or by maybe giving you a greater
aspect of influence over that.
So if you could just
tell the algorithm
you are interested in
that, that would probably
be the quickest,
simplest way for it
to be able to learn that.
So, yeah, and that's
incredibly challenging
to try and use this to give each
individual the best experience
when individuals vary so much.
I think one of
the big challenges
here is that we're
dealing with people.
And people are all
different and complicated.
And even compared to,
again, in my previous life
as a physicist, the underlying
systems were complicated.
But there were only
finitely complicated.
Whereas a person can have
so many different variations
and act in different
ways day to day.
So trying to come
up with things that
use the limited amount of data
that you have cleverly but can
also count for this really high
amount of individual variation
is a huge challenge.
AJA HAMMERLY: So
this is super cool.
I'm super into
personalization-based stuff
and spend a lot
of my early career
working on products with
personalization built in.
But I'm actually super curious
about how y'all are using GCP.
Because we have you on
the podcast because you're
customers.
So what does your
stock look like?
How did you make decisions?
What tools work really well
for these giant data science
problems?
RAVI UPRETI: As Matt
mentioned before,
we collect vast behavioral data.
So in order to do that,
how we use GCP is basically
we have a gateway where
all these events come
through the Qubit platform.
And we use actually
quite a bit of GCP
from Pub/Sub, which would
be responsible for acting
these buffers between
different data flows.
And data flows are
these logics, which,
for example, business logics,
like validations or enriching
things to actually
making sure that we
let our data enter
into BigQuery that we
use as a data warehouse.
On top of that, of course, once
we have the data in BigQuery,
then we let other
systems, for example,
Matt's machine learning systems,
to actually use that and create
something, in a
smarter intelligence,
thinks on top of that.
Also what we do with
these GCP pipelines are
it enables us to be real
time, so we can have
real-time solutions as well.
For example as a client or as
a user is browsing the site,
they might be changing from
a segment to a segment.
All of a sudden, a
first-time customer
becomes a first-time buyer
and things like that.
So we can out these real-time
solutions working as well.
And that helps us deliver better
personalizations, more reactive
or more real-time
personalizations.
AJA HAMMERLY: So what kinds of
decisions did you have to make?
And what did the
process look like
before you brought in
GCP's tools, like Pub/Sub,
and I think you all are
BigQuery users, too?
RAVI UPRETI: Yeah.
Yeah.
AJA HAMMERLY: And what
does it look like now?
Because the ability to do
machine learning in real time
is kind of awesome.
MATTHEW TAMSETT: So
yeah, for the past it
was quite different, actually.
Before we used to manage
our infrastructure
ourselves for asking
for bare-metal machines
from these providers to
actually having our own Hadoop
clusters over there.
Something that flows
[INAUDIBLE] real time
right now would before
look like, OK, we
see a behavioral information.
We store it somewhere
in a storage bucket.
And then we'd have
these massive batch jobs
that probably run once
a day in the evening
when we have to kind of
manually, most likely,
provision, so that, oh, we have
enough machines so that we can
run these jobs on time, to
actually an analyst waiting
for the next day to see, OK,
how was my day yesterday.
And how did our customers
behave yesterday?
They had to [? wait ?]
[? today. ?]
This actually moving
on to BigQuery
as an example, changed
from, well, you
could just query it faster.
So before, when we had
the Hadoop clusters,
you could run these hive
queries, which sometimes
even used to take
like hours to do
simple things like attribution
or other [INAUDIBLE],,
queries, to actually now being
able to do them sometimes
in seconds.
[INAUDIBLE] was in
minutes was amazing.
And, yeah, decision
for us-- so we already
had the pattern, the
pattern that works for us.
And it was so easy for us to
map these individual components
into something
that GCP provides.
So for example, if
we're using Kafka,
we know, OK, we could
just use Pub/Sub.
If we had Apache
Storm pipeline, we
knew we could just change it
very easy to Cloud Dataflow.
In terms of warehouse,
yeah, we're using Redshift.
And then we knew, OK, we
can use BigQuery for that.
We did try to sort of
Franken-cloud stuff, where
we had a few processing
happening on GCP
and trying to actually land data
to Redshift, which we realized
quite quickly was not working
for us because we were not
really able to stream data
that fast into Redshift
as we were into BigQuery.
And that was again, a big win.
AJA HAMMERLY: So it sounds
like you're using BigQuery.
It sounds like you're using
BigQuery partly because of how
fast it can ingest data.
Are you y'all using
BigQuery at ML at all?
MATTHEW TAMSETT: Yeah, so
we've been using BigQuery ML
I think slightly over a year.
I think we got involved
in the [INAUDIBLE] of it
fairly early on.
So some of our initial
reactions were, oh,
this is only like logistic
and linear regression, which
were quite simple models.
So at first, we
found it a little bit
easy to say, OK, that's not
for us because we were really
interested in getting the
absolute best performance
from any individual model.
But over time, I
think we sort of
realized that the real power of
that system wasn't in the fact
that it would train
the best model
for every single scenario.
It was that it would enable us
to do it really, really fast.
Qubit's infrastructure is
based around streaming events
from online touch points,
like browsers in real time,
and adjusting this
into BigQuery.
Now, because that's where all
of our behavioral data ends up,
we already have a lot of tools
that make this actionable
to you in your website.
So by that I mean
you can query out
what a user's done in
the past and enable
that to adapt their
future website experience.
Now, when BigQuery
ML came along,
that meant that we
could do not only
sort of historic
backwards-looking queries,
we could also train
new models to predict
forwards-looking things.
And that was done in the
system that was already
commoditized within Qubit.
So by that I mean we already
had all of the tooling and data
engineering around it.
That meant data
scientists' job changed
from writing a model
in the notebook,
building that into
a Python module,
deploying that somewhere,
worrying about how it scales
and how it's scheduled, and
the performance and the API,
to writing one query.
And the performance of that
model, like I said before,
is never going to be
better than the sort of,
the custom hand-built pipeline.
But it meant that
instead of taking weeks
maybe to build out a new use
case, you could do it in a day.
So I think once we
realized the speed
with which that
allowed us to innovate,
it completely changed things.
And we really decided to
invest a lot of time into it.
And one of the reasons I
think that works well at Qubit
is because we have this--
there's so many things you can
do with a user behavioral data.
And to explore all of
them in minute detail
would take many lifetimes.
So instead what we want to
do is explore a lot of them
fairly rapidly and work
out which ones give us
the biggest bang for our buck.
It's very easy to sort of judge
the quality of your models
by an offline performance
metric, you know,
how well it does
in your test set.
But really, for us,
what we care about
is does it change a
user's end experience?
Does this make a shop, an
online shop, more compelling
and give them something
that makes them want
to come back again and again?
So for us, the
proof of the pudding
is not whether this thing gets
a really good [INAUDIBLE] score
or whatever or some
other offline metric.
It's about whether when
deployed online drives
a meaningful change
to revenue or loyalty
or some other measure
of engagement.
So what we want to do there is
to explore all this rapidly,
get it in front of users, and
be able to learn from that.
And with the system
we already had
and the fact that BigQuery
ML is essentially just
BigQuery, yeah, we really
dove into it head first.
We've churned out more models, I
think, in the past three months
using this than we did in
the previous couple of years.
And it's really
interesting to see.
And then like I said
again, these things
end up in the hands of
our customers' customers
very quickly.
GABI FERRARA: I have a question.
So do you think that the
ability of using BigQuery ML--
because in the
end, it's basically
SQL that you're
writing on BigQuery ML.
Do you think that's a lower
barrier for, like let's say
you have new data scientists.
They may be able
to predict models
in a bit more of
cost benefit way,
as you said it before,
because the models,
now it doesn't take
that long to be refined.
Do you think that helps anyhow?
MATTHEW TAMSETT:
I'd say yes and no.
So most data scientists
when they come in
are very fluent in Python
or R or something like that.
So they tend to be very good
at doing their own feature
transformations and
churning their own model.
SQL is almost like a second
language to a lot of people
certainly we have here.
And though they're good at
it, it doesn't necessarily
give them all the
tools they'd be
used to in their everyday life.
So in some ways,
it's not as fast.
However, the breadth
of the people
within the company you
have access to SQL skills
is much larger than those
you have Python skills.
So what it does do is enable
people in other departments
to get involved a
lot more easily.
So product managers or product
specialists or analysts
or client engineers,
all of these people
suddenly can join in, as well.
I also think with SQL there's
a pretty steep learning curve.
But once you're over
the hill, then it
does become quite
quick to iterate.
So I'd say that's a bit
mixed, in some ways.
I think you've got a much wider
pool of talent you can draw on.
But sometimes it's not
the sort of power tools
that data scientists
would be used to.
GABI FERRARA: And
it's good to do
one thing like a [INAUDIBLE],,
take this out of the way
and do a quick thing instead
of having to create a network
and work all over.
Did you know or do you use
somehow other data sources,
other GCP products, other
databases, anything like that?
MATTHEW TAMSETT: So I
suppose Ravi would also
have a view on this.
But we use them for
different purposes.
So almost all of our behavioral
data ends up in BigQuery.
But we'll use different
databases for other things.
So for instance, my team
uses Cloud Data Store
to store configurations and
model summaries and things
like this.
And I'm not entirely clear
on the reasons for that.
Ravi can say more.
But it enables us to have
our Kubernetes deployments
dependent upon them.
So that if I just have a
model that I train in batch,
I can update the [INAUDIBLE] in
Cloud Data Store and restart.
That-- yeah, I guess
it's horses for courses.
Perhaps you should talk
about this a bit more, Ravi.
RAVI UPRETI: Yeah.
Apart from BigQuery, yes,
we use Bigtable a lot.
We use Memorystore
Redis as well a lot.
And this is something we are
experimenting with more right
now.
We have recommendations
right now
that uses [INAUDIBLE]
Redis in some other cloud.
And we want to actually
try it out here.
I think as Matt said
before, we usually
used to get access to
these things like as they
are introduced, like
in maybe alpha version.
So we were one of
the first customers
to actually try Cloud Bigtable,
where we build our solution
stash, which is where
you can keep certain user
attributes temporarily and then
access them online and kind
of add a bit of personalization
to certain experiences.
And we use Cloud SQL as well.
Yeah, so these are the
databases that we use.
GABI FERRARA: Just a follow
up, you mentioned Cloud SQL.
And do you use the new
feature for federated queries
inside BigQuery to Cloud SQL?
It's a beta feature.
RAVI UPRETI: No,
we don't use that.
But that is something, yeah,
we would love to try actually.
Because right now
we have a process
where we have
certain information,
but information, let's say,
around segments or experiences
that we could keep
in MySQL boxes, which
we would like to be used in
[INAUDIBLE] queries as well.
Right now what we do is we
try to sync it to BigQuery.
We do a bit of transformation
and sync it there.
So using the federated one
would be a good thing for us
to experiment actually.
What we have used
before is having
a bit of external tables.
So for example, if the
data is stored on GCS,
we have those kind
of external tables
and try to use it in
our different queries.
GABI FERRARA: Tell
me-- you mentioned
Python and R. What else eats
on your stock language wise?
MATTHEW TAMSETT: And so for
my team's point of view,
we have a bit of
history reflective
of the skills of
people who've joined
the company over the years.
So we have things in R, in
sort of the middle of our Stats
Engine, which is
the tool that we
use for measuring these
differences between A/B tests.
There's a bit of Stan in there.
And then layered on top of
that, we have C++ and Python.
And then from the data
science point of view,
that's pretty much
where it ends.
And we're in the process of
unifying that as we go along.
I think part of the
problem that we had
is that people come in
with different skill sets.
They're not software
engineers by training,
so they want to use the
tools that they've got close
at hand to solve problems.
But that can lead
to a proliferation
of languages over time.
So we're trying to sort of unify
under one umbrella in my team,
and that's Python.
All over the place
we used loads more.
So Ravi can talk about that.
RAVI UPRETI: Yeah,
for us we, use
Apache Beam SDK for
the data flows, which
is the Java one that we use.
We have lots of web services
that are built with a mix
of being in [? Go ?]
[? line ?] or in Java.
And then we do use
Python as well,
which is mostly for
our recommendations
ecosystem, the services
that we have there.
We use Python mostly because we
wanted data scientists as well
to get involved there.
Rarely, but we
have a few systems
which use [INAUDIBLE] as well.
And yeah, we use Apache Spark.
And we use-- actually
we use Dataproc from GCP
as well, where we spin up these
thousands of clusters where
we run our recommendation jobs.
And actually we use
quite a lot here,
spanning all these
different services.
AJA HAMMERLY: I know y'all
are doing a lot of events.
I got a little blurb
on your company,
and you're doing tons and
tons and tons of events
leading to tons and
tons and tons of data.
Do you have any particular
stories, [INAUDIBLE] stories,
or particularly
interesting anecdotes
you can share with us, days
that have been particularly
good or particularly bad?
I know that lots
and lots of times
we get a bunch of
nerdy folks together
that like to tell
about those days
where everything went wrong
or everything went great.
RAVI UPRETI: We used
to have such days,
so, for example, things
like Black Fridays,
where everybody all of a
sudden is looking for deals.
And the traffic
spikes are going up.
And the days when
we were managing
our own infrastructures,
those were the days
when it reminds you
of these movies where
you're putting out a fire.
So every day it would be like,
OK, people entering office
at 11:00 AM or 12:00,
and you're sort
of standing there clapping
for them because they
were up all night actually
managing these things.
So it used to be that bad.
But moving to GCP, we actually--
Black Fridays kind of became
a bit more manageable for us.
We could auto scale very easily.
We could provision systems
whenever we wanted to do,
rather than actually putting
a request in like a month
back or weeks back.
So those are the days
where I joined Qubit.
I remember everyday,
oh, this is down.
And being new, we didn't get
to get involved too much there.
But I knew other
people actually really,
really being involved there.
So those were the tricky days.
Christmas could
get tricky as well.
GABI FERRARA: So GCP
gave you back your sleep?
RAVI UPRETI: Yeah, it did.
AJA HAMMERLY: I can't think of
a more resounding endorsement
than that.
I totally get that.
Is there anything else that
y'all have experienced from
moving to the cloud versus
being on your own hardware?
Is there something
that makes easier,
stuff that it makes harder?
RAVI UPRETI: I think, easier.
Even the journey, the
beginning of the journey
to actually moving to cloud or
to GCP was how easy sometimes
it can be to prototype stuff.
So for example, I
remember when we
had to kind of move one of
these pipelines into GCP.
We're like, OK,
we have data flow.
There's the framework.
Let's see how quickly we can
prove that this will work.
And sometimes it used
to be like a day or two,
and we'll be done with
a proof of concept
that this is going
to work for us.
And in a month or
two, we would have
something which is
ready for production,
kind of this ability to actually
provide things very fast,
experiment a lot, and see
what really works for us.
And yeah, having this
serverless nature, where
all the engineers and
the infrastructure
can focus on solving
the problems that matter
rather than these problems that
everybody's solving everywhere,
we could just focus on the
problems that matter to us.
Yeah, and the speed of new
features coming in also
helps a lot, right?
Like, every now and then, you'll
have some new feature in one
of these products.
And you can quickly try it out.
And, yeah, that works for you.
And auto scaling,
obviously, I keep
on saying auto scaling is pretty
big for most of the products.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah,
auto scaling's
great there because that means
you're not paying for stuff.
You're not using-- how
about the data science side?
Is there anything that
is easier once you're
in the cloud in the
data science realm?
MATTHEW TAMSETT: So
I think, for me, it's
all about reducing the
amount of data engineering
my team has to do.
So we're not data engineers.
We're not software
engineers by training.
We can do these things.
But we're not really
the right people
to be doing them in
terms of speed and impact
and things like that.
So the thing I get most excited
about Cloud Services are tools
that can remove
part of that pain,
whether that's through enabling
me to easily train and host
my models in the cloud, or
if it's something as complete
as an [INAUDIBLE] solution,
where if I've got a data set
and I want to have a
first pass of a model,
I can just click a button and
pay as much as I want and get
a state-of-the-art
model out at the end.
So for me, it's
all about reducing
the reliance on other teams and
enabling us to quickly come up
with and test ideas and build
prototype models and scale
and experiment.
So for instance, we had a
period of time after Christmas,
I think last year,
where we were trying
to build out some
TensorFlow-based
recommendations models.
And we found we needed
40 machines with GPUs.
And we just have those.
And it's great, and
that was something
that was true in my
previous job to some extent,
in physics to some extent.
However, you'd be in a queue.
So the difference
there was that you
had these distributed computing
centers at universities
around the world.
But there was only
so many of them.
And so you potentially have
access to huge resources.
But you had to wait
for everybody else
to be done with them.
Whereas with the
cloud computing,
there is a limit to the scale.
But practically,
we don't see it.
So if we need 100 machines
at 10 minutes notice,
it really makes
better use of our time
or frees us up, to some
extent, because you're not
sitting around worrying
about the hardware.
You're not worrying about
debugging these distributed
systems that we don't
really understand.
It enables you to focus
the time on the statistics
and the machine learning
that we're here to do.
AJA HAMMERLY: That
totally makes sense.
It sounds like for both of you,
the advantages of the cloud
are getting to focus
on the parts that
are unique to your business
and/or you find interesting
and not having to focus
on the other bits.
That's why I like it, too.
Cool.
If folks are interested
in y'all product,
where can they learn
more about Qubit?
MATTHEW TAMSETT:
qubit.com, I think
is probably right place to go.
RAVI UPRETI: We have
certain blogs as well.
You could try
looking at the blogs.
Yeah, we usually are quite
active at Google Cloud
Next and things like that.
So you'll definitely find
YouTube videos for that, too.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
Well, we'll make
sure that there's
a link in the show notes
so that folks don't
have to type in all the issues.
Click on the link.
Well, thank you for being on
the podcast with us today.
It was very educational.
I love hearing stories about
people with cloud migrations.
GABI FERRARA: And
I love databases.
So it's really
nice to see people
talking that [INAUDIBLE].
MATTHEW TAMSETT: OK, great.
Thanks a lot.
RAVI UPRETI: Cool.
Thank you.
AJA HAMMERLY: So that was
a great conversation we
had with the folks from Qubit.
Now time for a
Question of the Week.
This week's question is, how do
you deploy a Windows container
on GKE?
Gabi, do you know?
GABI FERRARA: I possibly don't.
But I read it on the blog post.
And I think I can do it.
[LAUGHTER]
Basically, you need to have your
container image or container
registry.
And then once you have
that, there is a caveat.
It's you have to have a Linux
pool with one node at least.
But then you create
a Windows node pool,
and you can have your
containers deploy there.
That's the only thing that
I saw that was different.
And you need GKE 114
to be running that.
So that's how you do it.
It's on the blog post.
It's basically the
same YAML files
that you create for
Linux deployments.
Go there.
Check it out, so you can see
how to do it from Windows.
AJA HAMMERLY: That's awesome.
So where are you
going to be at, Gabi?
GABI FERRARA: I'll be on Google
Cloud Summit in Sao Paolo.
It's on the second
week of October.
And Aja, where you're
going to be going?
AJA HAMMERLY: I'm going to
be-- it's a long way out.
But I'm going to
be at Cloud Next
London in the end of November.
So if folks want to come
hang out at the Dub Zone
and say hi to me there, I
look forward to seeing them.
GABI FERRARA: Cool.
Thank you, all, for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]